have a question for you regarding the
Ensemble you're wearing did you know it
was going to be a hundred some odd
degrees you're wearing knits so you took
off the sweater already I have no idea
um it I'm just a natural sweater already
so it's not going to affect me too bad
I'm not sure if I'm sweating from the
Sun or from Encore Beach Club last night
it's already it's a the temperature's
hot so the heat is already brought all
right so how many beers in the cart
today there's gonna be plethora of beers
we're not going to throw a number count
on it there's also going to be Casa
azul's baby don't forget your tequila
Seltzer all right Travis have fun out
there I think he's going to guys
get over that Hill
yeah
right there stay right there
[Music]
go ahead drop one title baby we're not
Pros
I'm just telling y'all we're hit it
right over y'all's head nice and still
please thank you
thank you okay
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
five right there
top Tracer technology brought to you by
Capital reality go look at this how
about it
nice play by Travis Kelce on those guys
was up there and getting speaking some
wisdom it was uh it was an awesome year
man I can't wait to do it again every
single year it gets better and better I
think Chuck was all down
let me have one in the bunk hey man
yeah right there you also said clay was
gonna play the best out of everybody
put it in the tram I really want Pat try
a big boy in the water I'll jump in and
get the ball
now I want to hit it in
oh
hey thank you
yes sir go a little go little get in
here
all right there
this is how we got here right here these
salt pans baby yeah
a few holes left Chuck don't hey don't
talk me up too much I might have to
forgive you for ruining my Eagle Super
Bowl brother
if you ever forgave me yeah I forgive
you man
for you hey first of all your brother I
love your brother too so I was pulling
for my Egos and your brother
yeah you already know I got some
gangrene in my closet too so shout out
to all the eagles out there man go Birds
but you know the Chiefs had to get that
one man I've already lost the Super Bowl
and you won one I had to make sure my
brother at least felt that same pain I
felt
you're such a good brother you're such a
good brother you know that's it I'm just
a good good brother for that one
[Music]
[Applause]